(people chatting softly in the background)
(people gasp)
(bomb detonates)
(people scream)
(people continue screaming)
(sirens blaring)
(spacecrafts blaring)
- (whispers) Wait, wait, wait.
Gotta be careful here,
this place is crawling with them.
(high-pitched whoosh)
What was that?
- What?
- Cover me
- Guys! Hey guys!
Hey guys!
Oh thank God!
Yeah, we started a community of survivors.
Y'all come live with us.
(gun cocks)
(gun fires)
(gun fires again)
- Wait, how did you know?
- Come on.
Redneck wants us to
move into his community?
Us?
Let's go.
- All right.
(guns cock)
- Guys! Over here!
(laughs hysterically)
Oh thank god, there are other!
- Would you let me date your daughter?
- Of course!
(gun fires repeatedly)
(cloaking crackling)
- Oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god! (screams)
(guns cock)
Please don't hurt me!
My best friend's and I love Jay-Z!
And my favorite movie
is "Think Like a Man."
- She's good.
- Come with us.
- Okay.
- [Key] Stay close.
- What's your name?
- Emily.
- (in unison) Of course it is.
(dramatic suspenseful music)
- Hey, hey! Don't shoot, don't shoot!
- What do you think about the police?
- Well, I love their third album.
(gun fires repeatedly)
(man screams)
- I don't have any money!
I've no money! (screams)
(continues screaming)
(suspenseful music)
- Oh my god, oh my god!
Thank god you guys showed up!
I got to get outta here.
It's a silver Lexus.
Just pull it right up front
and don't scuff the paint, all right?
I just had it buffed.
(keys jingle)
(gun fires)
- Was he an alien too?
- Yep.
(dramatic music)
(footsteps)
(soft dramatic music)
- There's gotta be another
human being out there.
Somewhere.
It's been 173 days since the undoing.
(metallic scraping)
Today, I may be the last man alive.
However, if there is
another, I will find them.
The loneliness is more than I can...
(engine reeving)
(man whooping and cheering)
- There we go!
Let me get some of that!
(man groans and crunches loudly)
("Non-Stop Party" by Key & Peele)
♪ Well, tonight we gonna party ♪
Oh yeah! That's my jam
right there! (whoops)
♪ And the party don't stop
because it keeps on going ♪
(metallic scraping)
Huzzah!
She'll take ya!
Just like that!
Ooh, no not the butt though.
(smacks lips) Milady.
- Yo! Hey dude, how you doing?
- Yeah!
Oh yeah baby! (groans)
♪ ...All night ♪
♪ Friday night every night ♪
Oh hey!
Dude!
Hey, I'll come over there!
Dude, hey!
I'll come to you man!
(gun fires)
(music stops)
(soft dramatic music)
- There's gotta be another
human being out there.
Somewhere.
- [Voice Over Radio] The
zombies have broken through!
I repeat, zombies!
(man screams)
- Oh my god, Tommy's been bit!
(slow distorted music)
- Ah damn!
- Oh my god!
(men screaming)
Damn it! No, no!
- What are you waiting for?
You know what you have to do!
- No, I can't do it.
- [Bitten Man] Do what?
- You have to do it.
He's been bit!
(gun cocks)
- No, no, no, no!
- Forgive me Tommy!
(man screams)
(gun fires)
(man pants and gasps)
- (sobs softly) I can't
believe the zombies bit him!
- It wasn't a zombie
(sobs), it was a raccoon!
It's...the zombies are raccoons, right?
(thunder rumbles softly)
No? It's just zombies?
(thunder rumbles)
(electricity crackles)
Oh (beep), you just killed Tommy.
(dramatic music)
(guns cock)
- All right, listen up,
sheriff's department is close
by, we'll be safe there.
- Okay.
- Stay close.
I'll get you out of here.
(zombies snarling)
(man screaming)
(men screaming continuously)
- Oh my god!
They got Brett!
- What?
- They got Brett!
They got Brett!
- They didn't get us.
They didn't get us, okay?
We're still alive, but keep it together.
- Yeah, okay.
- We gotta make it to
that sheriff's station.
- Right.
Oh my god.
(zombies snarling)
(bell tolling softly)
- We got to go through them.
Just stay together, keep
moving, and don't get bit.
Go!
(suspenseful music)
(zombies snarling)
(men panting)
Are you getting this?
- Yeah, what is up?
All right, just go.
This is crazy.
(zombies continue snarling)
What...
- Ain't that some (beep).
- These are some racist
mother (beep) zombies.
- Why would you even lock the door?
I mean the windows broken and...
(zombie snarls)
(man gasps)
- Oh, hell no...
- That's...
- No, no, no.
(suspenseful music)
(zombies snarling)
Oh, come on!
- What is that?
- They seriously wouldn't let her eat us.
- Hey guys!
Isn't this great?
These racist zombies are leaving us alone.
Come on, we having a party.
("Party in the Mission"
by Latin Soul Syndicate)
The beer is here!
And look who I brought!
Come on, man.
(party-goers cheer)
♪ There's a party in the mission ♪
♪ There is only one condition ♪
(zombie snarling fearfully)
("Key and Peele Theme
Song" by Reggie Watts)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need, yuh ♪